this is the story of a game called sea
hero quest in both its mobile and VR
forms see her request tasks you with
memorizing Maps navigating a boat around
colorful seascapes and firing a flare
gun to Mark where you started but under
the surface seeing her request has a
much more important goal it hopes to
provide the data that could help
Humanity fight an incurable disease that
affects hundreds of millions of people
in Sea hero Quest you sail a small boat
around ocean mazes collecting missing
pages from your father's Journal he's
losing his memory and by retracing his
old Adventures you hope to help him
remember as the player begins each level
they are shown a map sometimes with
sections that are faded or completely
missing and tasked with navigating to a
point or series of points from memory
once the player Begins the level they
cannot check the map again without
restarting at the end of each level the
player either retrieves a missing page
often seeing a giant friendly sea
creature in the process or is tasked
with firing a flare gun back to where
they began with stars dished out for how
quickly you complete the task
some levels have you navigating through
fog or throw up surprises to throw you
off course and later levels become
pretty difficult to remember this
nightmare roundabout for example took me
several attempts to complete now this
might sound like any other mobile game
but there's actually a lot more going on
here and to understand that we need to
meet the people who designed the game
not just developers but scientists too
this is Hugo Spears he's a professor of
cognitive neuroscience at University
College London and his research focuses
on the ways in which people navigate
environments and how that changes when
people suffer Dementia or Alzheimer's
disease one of the earliest symptoms you
might see in Alzheimer's dementia is
people becoming disoriented certainly
going somewhere new they'll get confused
more than they used to and it seems that
that now predates that in their lifespan
the the memory problems you typically
associate like forgetting everything if
we can understand people's spatial
Behavior how they navigate better you
can start to build tools that might
detect the subtlest changes that might
occur for someone and Alzheimer's
disease one of the big problems with
researching these changes is that it's
incredibly difficult to test how people
navigate Big environments in a lab
setting and it's incredibly time
consuming testing people one by one but
back in 2016 a phone call from Michael
hornberger a professor of dementia
research at the University of East
Anglia sparked an idea could we build a
video game that could be provide a mass
population of people monitor the data
coming out of the video game and build
this monitoring tool to capture the the
earlier signs of being disoriented in
Alzheimer's and so Michael and Hugo were
introduced to Max Scott Slade the
founder of an indie developer named
glitches glitches was formed to
effectively build games that had some
kind of creative or technological leap
every single project we wanted to work
on had to do something that pushed the
boundaries of gains in some way I really
wanted to learn as much about the
experiments they were already doing not
only what the experiments were but how
the data was valuable for their research
so then we could try and and manipulate
the the design of the game to facilitate
all of those questions with glitches and
in association with the charity
Alzheimer's research UK Michael and Hugo
assembled a team of other
neuroscientists and secured funding for
the project from Deutsche Telecom
alongside marketing and Communications
company Sachin Sachi not exactly your
typical games industry collaboration
[Music]
it quickly became clear that this would
not be a typical game development
process as well as making it fun the
team needed to ensure that the game
would stand up as a legitimate
scientific study so we couldn't have
collectible coins for example because
that would be attractive to the player
to go towards all kinds of things
actually subconsciously become
navigational aids for the human brain we
couldn't have shadows that would lead
the player to believe they were facing
one way or another and we couldn't have
a son in the sky the only thing that
they were allowed to use was the
environment itself and the landmarks
that were placed around the level as
they play the player's position and
movement around the level is relayed to
the researchers in the form of data each
decision of whether to turn left or
right speed up or slow down helps paint
a picture of how people navigate The
Mazes and the accuracy of their flare
shooting helps measure how well oriented
the player is when they reach their
destination when the game is played on a
mass scale this allows the researchers
to see population level statistics for
how well people are able to navigate The
Mazes across different age groups gender
identities nationalities and so on this
method of data collection the game
employs is about 150 times faster than
traditional dementia research while
still remaining completely
scientifically valid the question now
was how many people would actually play
the game Michael and you got really
excited if they could collect 10 000
people I said look I think we need to be
more more extreme with our predictions I
think we can probably do a hundred
thousand people for context a typical
dementia study might feature a hundred
participants if the researchers were
lucky but if a hundred thousand people
played C hero quest for just two minutes
it would generate the same amount of
data as 50 50 years of traditional
dementia research they were Aiming High
but if they could achieve it a hundred
thousand players would be a game changer
it was the day of the launch one of the
Deutsche Telecom crew came over and said
to me we've just gone over a hundred
thousand participants or a hundred
thousand players so we did the sort of
like wishful thinking number in the
first 10 hours it was jaw-dropping
really when we saw the numbers rack up
of how many people were generating data
I can't think of any other tests out
there that's as precise as this because
there's just so many people who helped
out with the research in the first week
we had over a million and and now the
project I in total over the course of
its life when it was available was a
consumer game on the App Store four and
a half million people played that game
the strategy around reaching out and the
effort made to reach people was just
phenomenal far beyond any research study
I've seen them just wonderful to see
that work
over the course of its Journey the 4.4
million players who played see hero
Quest provided Hugo Michael and the team
with data that would have taken
traditional dementia research 17
000 years to collect from a diverse
Global pool of participants see
heroquest is by far the largest dementia
research project in history and it
wasn't just traditional Gamers playing
the game either when you look at the
demographic spread of who played the
game over 195 countries were logged as
having people playing it we have people
right their way through from 18 to the
90s playing the game actually seeing
older people come to games because of
the content and family members who
wanted to support someone who had been
through Alzheimer's dementias and sadly
lost them they felt empowered by a video
game and I love that I thought that was
so amazing to be able to do that in the
years since its release in 2016 the data
collected by sea heroquest has proven
its worth as a research tool and helped
scientists around the world understand
stand more about how Alzheimer's disease
and dementia develops so one thing is
that we've been able to show that the
game Seer request does a better job of
distinguishing people a high genetic
risk of Alzheimer's the tests will pick
them up better than the gold standard
measures for tracking Alzheimer's
disease that's where we really see the
value in having a test like this to kind
of help with that it's literally levels
from the game so we haven't modified it
so that's the value here is that
spending all that careful time at the
glitches trying to build the game very
carefully it means we now have this full
test that is that game
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're watching this video chances
are you love games and if you're
anything like me the idea of scientists
and developers using the medium you love
to make the world a better place is
incredibly exciting as for Hugo and Max
their hope is that this is just the
beginning there is really a huge benefit
I can see between bringing psychologists
together with uh with games developers
to do more and my view is They Don't
Really the games developers don't need
to do much more than what they're doing
it's about connecting up and sharing the
data really so I'm optimistic but I
think it's going to take more effort
it's not a simple this is a no-brainer
it's going to take more effort but I am
optimistic that it more will be more
will happen yeah when see hero had that
kind of success it really changed my
mind about what kind of projects I
should be working on as a designer
developer I'm always going to chase the
problems we should solve as a society
games are so powerful and I think we
need to stop thinking of them purely as
entertainment and I don't think we
should go away from that because I think
that's what makes them so engaging I
think we need to start thinking them as
tools as utilities to do something other
than just entertain we're just at the
beginning the whole thing is is open to
sort of tipping on its head I believe as
of the time of recording see hero Quest
is no longer freely available to play
although glitches do tell me they plan
to relaunch the game in full next year
thankfully if you don't want to wait
until next year Hugo and glitches have
set up this email address that's on
screen now and down in the bio if you
want to play see her request and help
contribute to the data set feel free to
email them and you'll be sent an access
code to play a series of levels from the
game there is still no cure for
Alzheimer's disease or dementia but
perhaps in years to come we'll look back
on see her request and the research It
produced and realize it marked a kind of
turning point in the fight against the
disease we're all pretty used to seeing
video games getting vilified in the
media for all sorts of reasons and even
catching the blame for some real world
problems which is why I think see her
request is worth celebrating it's a
fantastic example of video games being
used to make the world a better place as
Max says let's hope this is just the
beginning